this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history
and today because you guys asked for it
a lot
he's going to be breaking down the guns
of 2019's call of duty modern warfare
to see how accurately they're portrayed
within the game
and of course we have the hip fire
minigun
long story short no let us know if there
are any other games guns or mechanics
you want jonathan to break down
but right now here's call of duty modern
warfare can't go loud
need a suppressor
that'll do it okay first pause
so we've just seen our protagonist
retrieve
an automotive component from a car's
engine bay
and anyone that's played the game will
know this is a cars
oil filter which is magically being
attached to the muzzle
of this pistol this uh 1911 type pistol
now you can make without going into any
details
a sound suppressor of sorts from an oil
filter
suffice it to say you cannot screw it
straight onto the end of a gun
it's also not potentially going to last
very long it's not going to be very
efficient
as a suppressor the amount of sound
suppression you're going to get from
this
is going to be relatively minimal people
will still hear a gun going off
good eye
the sound suppressor is also far too
quiet um it's not quite hollywood pew
pew
there's a bit of meat to the to the
sound there but
for gameplay purposes obviously it's
quite muted way more than what this
repurposed bit of equipment could
provide
the left
awesome so we've switched now to the the
infamous deagle
with the same um oil filter sound
suppressor on it
sound suppressors on desert eagles are
um
rare shall we say because there isn't
much point to the desert eagle in the
first place
making it quieter is not usually
something people want to do
this was a surprise when i was playing
through the game myself
we have the german car 98k
uh rifles carbine of the second world
war and we have it fitted with a sniper
scope this is a genuine configuration of
the second world war
period there's quite a strong tradition
in call of duty of course of
uh callbacks to the old world war ii and
now the newer world war
ii card games so seeing a car 98k
in the campaign is almost expected but
obviously in context you think well why
we're in a modern conflict zone here why
do we have this
second world war bolt action rifle it's
not
completely implausible these pretty
robust well-made
powerful capable rifles are still around
they have been used
certainly in afghanistan they have been
used to engage allied forces with so
they're definitely a a real threat where
they're used they're just not
perhaps super common and certainly with
a with a sniper scope on there in good
enough condition to actually use it'd be
pretty surprising
to see that in real life
and we've seen our first use there of
the what's called in the game the odin
12.7 millimeter 50 caliber assault rifle
50 caliber assault rifle is
feels like a contradiction in terms but
um okay so
anyone isn't aware this is a real weapon
russian uh russian design
known as the um h-12 this thing is
developed for the
fsb the successor to the kgb
so specifically developed for people
that need to counter terrorism
essentially so if a terrorist is wearing
body armor this thing is going to
to bypass that
and that that 12.7 bullet is really
quite nicely modelled in terms of the
sound
effects and sort of visceral feel of
firing it and the effect on the
virtual bad guys of course it's kind of
interesting that you don't have to make
things up
to introduce something new and
interesting to a long-running series
like this
pausing now this was the level that i
enjoyed the most playing through the
campaign myself i hesitate to say
enjoyed because it's got a bit of real
world
uh resonance to it but thinking of the
old school rainbow six games
counter-terrorist stuff i found really
quite compelling in the game
we're playing here as members of the
sas of course although it might not be
their primary armament
they have been seen in public with the
sig mcx now as we are
a contemporary collection here and we
try to keep as up to date as we can
we do actually have an example of the
sig mcx
so just like in the game and it's a
pretty faithfully modeled weapon
caliber the the basic configuration of
the receivers
is pretty spot-on it's very a very
modular weapon
which fits call of duty's modular
approach with the gunsmith in terms of
how you configure the weapon in
different ways
that makes more sense with a modern
weapon like this than it does with some
of the others that are in the game
now what would a call of duty modern
warfare game b
without an m4 or something like it with
the m203 40 millimeter grenade launcher
mounted under the barrel the version
depicted here
is um not a million miles away from
what's sitting behind me now this is
such a common configuration
this is the canadian um demarco now cult
canada
equivalent to what we see in the game so
very similar
and then we have the m203
which you open up just like in the game
insert a cartridge
close it up and fire it in terms of the
the effects of what we see with this
hybrid weapon effectively
the the blast effects are quite well
done i think uh games have improved in
that respect
uh years ago we'd have seen a fireball
when a grenade either a
hand-thrown grenade or an under-barrel
grenade was was fired
now it's much more of a blast effect
with sort of dust or whatever's in the
environment
and um can't see them but you know your
characters being where or the enemy is
being wounded by
effectively projectiles and that's how
grenades work in real life
something we've seen from the first
modern warfare onwards is
an on-screen grenade site with a sort of
ladder reticle
which um i've never got on very well
with but um so you get an on-screen
aiming
which is a bit of a throwback really we
have iron sights we have optical sights
it's interesting that we don't aim our
underground grenades
using the actual sights on the weapon we
still use the reticle on the screen so
i'm
waiting for that to catch up
ah the uzi a classic cold war era
firearm which of course is still in um
use today albeit not very widespread use
having said that um in the sort of
conflict zones that we see depicted in
the game
they're still around they're very robust
they're relatively easy to maintain
it's well depicted as well um the rate
of fire
is accurate which um i've mentioned
because
most uvs in games have not been and
they're using quite a slow rate of fire
about 600 rounds per minute partly what
makes it so controllable than the weight
of the thing it's quite heavy for
such a small gun unless you're um arnold
schwarzenegger and you can hold it
out in one hand and still apparently hit
what you're aiming at
check this out 338 lapua armor piercing
at 600 meters
i put it together myself please
pausing this was a bit of a head
scratcher moment in the campaign
when i came across the hdr i thought i'd
um
blip sideways into advanced warfare or
something because it's a very futuristic
on the face of it
wacky looking rifle the guy says he made
it himself
which is impressive i should say that
that's completely plausible for for many
weapons
in in particular in the uh kaiba region
of pakistan
as some people will already know
firearms are made
on relatively basic tooling sometimes
even by hand
and they're reboot they are rebuilt from
factory-made assemblies and components
as well so the idea of someone in
this sort of transitional middle eastern
south sort of asian area of the world or
indeed elsewhere in the world being able
to make a gun himself is completely
plausible
but it just doesn't kind of jibe with
the visuals this thing is clearly a
some sort of advanced and as he says
himself 338 lap or a magnum
sniper rifle a precision weapon but it
was a nice moment in the campaign
because you feel like you've got this
thing that has the power and the
precision to take on these vehicles that
are attacking
something i like about this is the the
vapor trail of the bullet
it might not be quite what you'd see in
real life but um
the effort to replicate the visuals of a
big heavy bullet
smashing through uh moisture in the air
which does create this sort of spiral
trail
you can actually see where your bullets
are going at long range so let's
add something i think to depict it in
the game
pausing this this was another slightly
confusing moment for me playing through
this originally
so we're into this nighttime level and
to see the weapon in usb and m14
took me aback slightly especially with
the with the red dot sight used for the
cqb
type fighting the m14 a 1950s
battle rifle full power cartridge
semi-automatic and you may well put a
suppressor on it to reduce your sound
signature
the fact that you're running around with
a close quarter battle site on it
is what uh didn't quite tally but
traditionally you'd see something like
this with a magnified
optical sight on it and it would be for
medium range
out to perhaps 800 meters not shooting
people in the face
in the dark and the the sound suppressor
report that we get from this rifle is
very hollywood
almost like a like a laser sound i'd
expect
a much sort of louder pop sound so we
see the player here taking out lights
with the m14 this is a quite a common
legitimate use of a suppressed weapon
in this sort of situation so it's a an
interesting real world gameplay mechanic
if that if that makes sense
to use it to take out light
so the the svd or draganov sniper rifle
as it's known in russian doctrine anyway
and it's
uh it's an 800 meter rifle um which we
don't
typically see it capable of in in call
of duty games
here we see it used indoors a bit more
of a cqb environment
makes some sense in that because it
comes with a mount for a scope
you're able to fit a thermal optic and
you're kind of you're a bit hampered by
the rate of fire of the svd but it's
powerful just like in real life
so it will tend to take down bad guys
pretty quickly
so we've got the um the dp12 shotgun
here
the real key feature here is probably
the incendiary rounds that's firing
which have a real world parallel in
in what's called dragon's breath so it's
it's a real round and it really will set
stuff on fire that's what incendiary
means of course
a load of buckshot is more
devastating to to a human body than an
incendiary round would be
it would certainly have unpleasant
effects it would certainly be effective
to some extent but it's not something
that's going to see real world use
targets we see there another grenade
launcher but a standalone grenade
launcher originally a south african
design the milk or mgl in the museum
collection
one of the early versions it's an
interesting weapon because it has this
wind-up revolver mechanism so you wind
that up to a certain number of clicks
and then when you pull the trigger
it releases it to the next chamber and
fires a shot
very effective for exactly what we see
in the game there might be a marksman
engaging your
your squad you can lob in explosive
shells that will
stop them from shooting at you pretty
much the sort of thing this was designed
for
causing and of course we have the hip
fire minigun beloved of action movies
and
video games like i've been fortunate
enough to hold
the the rig from predator and terminator
2 once when i'm on a trip to the states
long story short no as it turns out
slightly more plausible than i ever
believed somebody has loaded one up
and buys it you can find the video on
youtube and a handful of rounds go
roughly where he wants which is a
handful more than i thought you know i
thought it would be one round vaguely in
the target area and then
the recoil of three and a half to five
thousand rounds per minute which i think
is higher than what we see in the game
would just swing you off to the side you
can do it but you need a battery pack so
you need wires
trailing back to a 24 volt battery i
think it is
you need tremendous amounts of
ammunition you cannot carry all of that
around
unless you are a t-800 or jesse ventura
okay guys that's it thank you for
watching this breakdown of the weapons
of call of duty modern warfare
2019 with me um i've enjoyed it i hope
you have too
[Music]
[Music]
you